is that the kind of stuff that you feel
like you're you know are you are having
with your son the conversations because
there's a lot of conversations being had
right now about everything going on and
even talking to some of my friends you
know they're like I'm having to have
really hard conversations with my kid
they're getting the driver's license I'm
like hey if a cop pulls you over I don't
care what happens I just want you to
come home like whatever like are you
having to have those conversations as
well it's like when I have to explain
why the protest but not with the death
they were to say to put me in those
awkward situations upon a little older
my little girl six and it's like you
know she catches something like the news
or something and it's like you know I
just have to explain it simple and it's
just like well there's just right and
wrong and this person and that's why
they're crying but I just it's a very
different thing you know and and I think
that's a parent now more than ever
me having a conversation with my little
white girl and you having a conversation
with your little blog that's a very
different conversation you know so and I
think everyone needs to have that
uncomfortable conversation that that
exists and it's wrong and this is true
when you get to it's also delicate yeah
over exert these things to him and this
perspective on it at the same time you
know it's different and they know how
you know like even my boy and my girl
they're so different like how they
receive information and you know it goes
in and out his ear and she is a sponge
so I know they are all different
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going